كنت هكذا هو الواقع الجديد لمعظم التفاعلات الشخصية هذه الأيام وجهاً لوجه الآن عبر الإنترنت بسبب الوباء الطمع في هذا العالم الجديد ، يجد رواد الأعمال مثل فرودو فينتاكيا فرصًا لتنمية أعمالهم مرحبًا دكتور باوتشا صباح الخير صباح الخير لورين كيف حالك أنت تقوم بذلك ، أنا أفعل هذا ، شركة okadak للتطبيب عن بعد التي تتخذ من دبي مقراً لها والتي تسمح للمرضى بالاتصال فعلياً بأطبائهم قررت Frodol إطلاق okadak بعد تجربة حجز غير سارة شعرت بالمرض وأردت فقط حجز موعد مع طبيبي الخاص. خلال أيام العمل خلال ساعات العمل ، واستغرق الأمر أكثر من 15 دقيقة حتى لا أحصل على موعد كان من المقرر إطلاق منصة okadak للتطبيب عن بعد في نهاية عام 2020 ، لكن ferdil تتبع سريعًا الإصدار بسبب جائحة الفيروس التاجي ، نحن حرفيًا الفريق بأكمله نحن لقد عملنا ليلاً ونهارًا لأسابيع وكان ذلك رائعًا لأننا مستخدمون وعائلاتنا كذلك  باستخدام هذه
المنصة لذلك نرى بالتأكيد
فوائد أه من ذلك ولكن
تسارعه تمامًا أعتقد
أننا لقد اكتسبنا للتو عامين وثلاثة
أعوام من حيث التبني على الأقل
يربط okadak المرضى بأكثر من
خمسة عشر  مائة طبيب يعملون في
مائة وستين مستشفى في جميع
أنحاء الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، يمكن للمستخدمين
تصفية الأطباء بناءً على
التغطية التأمينية للغة المنطوقة ومجالات
الخبرة ، كل ما نحتاج إلى القيام به هو إرسال
وصفة طبية لإعادة الملء
، لقد كانت رائعة بالفعل من نواح كثيرة
أولاً وقبل كل شيء  لقد ساعدنا ذلك خلال
أزمة سيئة حقيقية عندما اضطررنا
للتواصل مع مرضانا وأنت تعلم
أنه كان وقتًا صعبًا للغاية بالنسبة لنا
وكان من
المهم جدًا أن يرى المرضى
طبيبهم وجهاً لوجه ولكن المضي
قدمًا على ما أعتقد  سوف يغير الكثير
منا غدًا. لدي زيارة للتطبيب عن بعد
مع شخص ما في كندا ، لذلك أرى أن
هذا يتحول إلى العالمية حقًا حيث سنكون
قادرين على البقاء على اتصال مع مرضانا
كل
يوم  تستمر التداعيات الاقتصادية الناجمة عن السرية
19 في تعطيل الأعمال التجارية في جميع
أنحاء العالم ،
ولكن بالنسبة لبعض رواد الأعمال مثل fodo ،
فإنهم يجدون طرقًا لتنمية شركاتهم
كلير سيباستيان